ho tirato il caffè addosso gli ho
rovinato la vita
solo oggi ci teniamo djokovic avete
richiesto in tantissimi giocheremo al
meglio dire e cioè anni dalla nascita
fino a morta in questo gioco dovremo
fare varie scelte che ci porteranno a
cose positive o cosa linea diverso
partita attenta e prendete i pop corn
mette assieme i comodi ed eccoci qua
iniziamo proprio dall'inizio mi
raccomando se non avete lasciato mi
piace la testa progresso 5 mila mi piace
faremo anche il continuo
anzi su questo video raggiunge i 6 mila
mi piace vitale sarà la strada signore
non riesce a dare anche se vediamo chi
ha una vita migliore che iniziava subito
chi ti devi premere ok ci sono riuscito
come ci siamo riusciti ora dove ma
perché non ci sono le termine sono
paschi che carini mi chiami da giusta
maschio cosa succede auguriamo carini
che stiamo 16 mano dei silenzi la carne
o no vabbè vabbè non ci credo che ho
perso già a un anno tiriamo al conteggio
di quante volte lo yogurt
riproviamo che dobbiamo seguire la palla
ma non ha funzionato piuttosto secondo
vediamo così altra prova ci aspetta due
anni giochi avanti con il mouse
attentati corri corri corri corri non
possono camejo il colpo gattonando
essere spiaccicato dai 12 8 normale che
succede a 23 anni non sono ancora morta
sono una volta travolta vediamo che se
succede a tre anni
sbaglia scolare e impara dominare o no
devo scegliere un giocattolo il basso o
il cavaliere ma è invaso mises spray
nel senso che vediamo il cavaliere
mediamo è l'ho distrutta penso che cosa
succederà se prendevi il vaso terra bene
bene bene
lo spread come reagirà che sia un po
arrabbiato
poverino ipad grazie a una stella in
mezzo e che cosa vuol dire
sei tu a camminare
si è chiusa ma perché non diventate così
grande a tre anni ma questo non è un
bambino di tre anni numero di 5 35 anni
non si è passati a 4 castelli ci sono
scuola adesso è l'ora di pranzo in vita
la amoroso o mangia da solo ma evitiamo
un braccio vediamo
si parla di comencini invito a pranzo
però mangiano in questa prova di 5 anni
a casa felici diamo sei anni ma che
mario scanni è che non è stato mai
pulito di gialli porco l'anno prima
sotterrato nel giardino poi lo hanno
tirato fuori ha detto beva puliamo la un
laghetto bello ci sono gli amici e pesco
o mi unisco a loro uniamoci alloro
sediamo e contro molto entusiasmo un
solo
alla faccia dello sparo di tutti no ma
magari una balena e meno male abbiamo
tutti interi dicono di costruire una
zattera le piume
m io costruire una zattera io di tiro ma
ci sono anche delle ruote centro dai una
mano sia lo stile penso tutti alla
stessa giornata no goal a chi dobbiamo
usare le piume ma anche senza come
facciamo uscire dalla pancia della
balena con le piume e soprattutto destra
da dove uscita quella vissuta è spuntato
il tecnico secondo me era un dinosauro
allenarmi vediamo cosa ci aspetta a 8
anni a dobbiamo inseguire di tipo
acchiapparello dobbiamo prendere tutti
amici apparendo bravo workers che
marchionne farebbe io so per chi ha
molto a che fare non lo so chi è malato
questo gioco vediamo che propose a
spetta a noi andiamo in camera di notte
a lui in alto io sono zucchero indice ci
vestiamo da claudio do paraná io dico da
bar
noi diciamo reale
wow che bello che sto vestito ma c'era
una banana o sbaglio ok ci sono la mia
festa preferita
vediamo che cosa succede se bauman
marchio su batman
sì c'è spiaccicato mai visto sapremo
vestirsi pamparana ma che batman il
nemico e joker il club quindi per averlo
joker
ok è molto più bello non fa paura perché
questi vestito la vediamo sopravviviamo
batman si sta mandando fuori dolcetto
scherzetto forte wow
adoro a lui andiamo nella carta carina
bella nella carta paura o rosa nella
casa paurosa vediamo una mummia 9 c'è
ancora interno vedi che ha la testa
grazie
gambero piscina stiamo imparando a
nuotare
c'è un altro bambino però che già sa
nuotare mi dice continuate a sei pronto
io continuo ad allenarmi perché con
favore che però caso un'ora dopo l'uomo
ha imparato e mangiando solo
vediamo di gianni cosa succede macchina
possiamo già guidare la macchina da un
pezzo andata neanche quelli che attrezza
li puoi abbinare la macchina che stati
uniti la macchina di nostro padre è
normale a 11 anni prima il gabinetto ma
poi la macchina 12 anni stiamo in chiesa
prega per la pace nel mondo
oslo dio non esiste preghiamo per la
pace del mondo che cosa forse sono
riuscito a tenere la base del mondo sarà
cosa facile ma questa probabilità adesso
riusciamo ancora vediamo atrizia
diventeremo giganti 30
vediamo come manchi beatrice di tribù
così vicino menage quindi questa è una
ragazza che mi piace
vediamo più rilassata ma che per come ce
ne sono scomparsi guarda il potere
dell'invisibilità camminare quanto ci
sono e c'è qualcosa che non quadra
chi è bancato il gioco no
ok prima il gioco purtroppo dire a barga
tomas e quale si debba fare ai 14 anni
abbiamo parlato con la nostra cras
vediamo ora che succede eccetera tipo di
nuovo a scuola stavamo andando dalla
nostra classe c'era solo scoperto il
bullo della scuola che faccia combatto o
continuo a camminare no bisogna
ignorarli bull
i bulli e vuole quindi partire a
camminare vendiamo miei spinto rosa
guardando bene dispiace perché sono io
che ho scelto questa setta riproviamo mi
hanno eliminato
come fare quindi devo più imbattere
speriamo di riuscirci dopo ferma si
hanno casa primato cosa dovrei parrozzo
siamo con salvezza non rosso guarda
[Musica]
un modo verso povere nuova riproviamo
poveri non mi dispiace li ho reso la
vita difficile a questo ragazzo
so che questa volta di sconfiggere loro
racconto richiamo ai poveri ma non c'è
nessuno ma è tra professoressa quasi via
controlla mazzi brava vecchia di questo
punto è che passo di un minuto dubbi ma
credo la fidanzata indici anni vediamo
che prova dovremo affrontare adesso
stiamo un po male forza no è mattina e
stiamo perche degli atti forse non si
volevano svegliare per quello che sta
male
guai a scuola tanti la scuola ma vediamo
però non stia il bullo di nuovo stavo
entrando in classe
guarda che c'è ha detto era facilissima
questa prova dei 15 anni ora dove fino a
dove stiamo arrivando
faccio un giro fu tornato indietro se
non era la scelta giusta che siamo al
parco ecco questi sono i nostri amici
sono gli stessi che sono finiti nella
buca della sony non sono sempre loro c'è
anche la mia classe concorrente da
dentro al bosco perché è semplicissimo e
16 anni cosa dovremmo affrontare vediamo
senza tra la cosa continua la nostra
avventura non mi dica che ora arriva
un'altra barriera che si ma insomma c'è
il laghetto ma si sono buttate dare così
rimasto gara di tuffi stato non tanto
dai parrocchiani ma vediamo youtube si è
bloccato il tempo qualche tuffo tutti i
mestieri dunque fatto un'altra stella
diventano cose grazie e vi cito master
grandi a 16 anni ce l'abbiamo 30 va bene
ci sono
dovevo stare che cerchiamo di fargli
fare una bella vita
serino cellulare
inutile sua sì allora alice e xiaobo io
vederli tutti o liga a noto e quindi
devo scegliere olga non posso tornare
indietro ma basterà olga la mia
fidanzata martina cosa mi porterà aver
scelto olga come sarà la mia vita hanno
mangiato stanno giocando le zucchine
caffè sembra simpatica olga negozio di
gioielli
ci sono due anelli uno che costa 100
dollari è uno che costa ben 20.000
dollari ma ci siamo appena conosciuti
l'opposto giacche nere di sposarmi
quindi prendere l'anello terza certa è
che non si arrabbi vediamo braga braga
era super triste però lui stai dicendo
io un ballerino solo perché non ha
comprato l'anello costoso gaia cagliari
noto pochino succederà ora
i due amanti 2 cellulare per loro
messaggiando dice come va
vuoi uscire io dico è che le dico come
va o come stai come squadra e vediamo
per favore ai due mondi o parlami
proviamo bar parlano in serie d sparisci
a risso per me un anello si oppone
perché diritto e bella di questo gioco è
che quando fai le scelte cambiano poi in
corso da un destino di questa persona
altro modo telefono ma sta chiamando si
vedrà
stiamo andando bene dare porta forse
siamo riusciti a fargli fare una
bellissima vita forse ricevo vivere fino
a 100 anni per beating farlo vivere fino
a personaggi allora solo giro con olga
[Musica]
no sto mandando tutto bellissimo
un altro ragazzo che aveva una macchina
bella di cerchiamo ci porta o la povera
perché lo avrà un viaggio e poi per
terra si spiaccica attraverso la nostra
poverino forse abbiamo fatto qualche
scelta sbagliata esata olga ad esempio
cediamo questo ci aspettano altri 25
anni
secondo me diventa sempre più difficile
adesso abbiamo manager abbiamo un caffè
e fluttuante
io pensavo che stesse facendo il mago
che stessa cosa stesse facendo fluttuare
caffè non abbiamo messo qualche bug
mancheremo stato tirato il caldo sopra
la maglietta bianca pulita è vero dice
pulisci il caffè che caduto oppure tira
un pugno di ricerca
ok sto pulendo il caffè questo quindi il
nostro manager nostro cup ci sono i tubi
neri stessa come l'impressione che
abbiamo fatto qualche scelta sbagliata
perché le cose fa mi ami termico andare
male se voi avete giocato a questo gioco
come è andata per voi che cos'è romani
che ha male alla pancia ma di stomaco
dice bene il bagno delle donne degli
uomini muovendo il bagno delle donne
e allora proprio urgente mi sa
oppure
un rinato beh penso che siamo
ho accettato pugni in faccia no invece
non possiamo e dobbiamo tagliare
l'orinatoio per fare che cosa
mediato o fate un cattolici piace
davvero l'unico aiuto sanno all'uso blu
peggio paure che non sopravviva qualcosa
prima di nove anni
vediamo se continuiamo con forza che
qualcuno su picchierà la mani una
macchina che cosa c'è domina dollari e
una da 150mila dollari
beh io prenderei quella che costa meno
anche se quella mia casa era infatti
quella bianca costa troppo prendo quella
blu è vero che forse andata bene allora
eccoci qua stiamo ai 30 anni ea mangiare
sono la macchina mia nuova macchina
bellissima e col gara con quell'altro
predazzo basta che meglio più nulla la
macchina il nuovo e bella stava tornando
da noi ma noi abbiamo accelerato il 31
anni vediamo forse forse va meglio
adesso un nuovo veloce fin sulla
macchina ci hanno vandalizzato la
macchina non sporcate secondo messa
sulla finanza
sì oppure olga stesso che abbiamo
ripulito la stabile vediamo cosa ci
aspetta quelle 32 hai tu eri tu che
vieni qua dice fa paura la mia
macchinetta del caffè a casa smesso di
funzionare
mica siamo tecnici della macchina
fotografica puoi venire a casa e
aggiustarla per me vi posso scegliere di
dire sì signore oppure no scusa sono
impegnato e no scusate fa paura per
tanti paesi in testa quindi mi continua
si licenziano o non regolare che le voci
che noi abbiamo perso il lavoro
no mi dispiace presto facendo fare una
vita trattata 33 anni viviamo noverino
diventato senza tetto sta chiedendo le
mogli sono stato provinato la vita di
polizia o no hay signora è illegale
essere senza tetto legale poverino non è
colpa tua se non ci credo ma nessuno vi
se prendi la pistola oppure fatti
arrestare o trottola risparmi parti
arrestare anche se almeno così avremmo
una casa solo perché non sono andato ad
aggiustare la macchina del caffè ma 33
non l'abbiamo già fatto sì che c'è un
altro 33 che forse il continuo zone no
mi dispiace per lavori per fermarlo
tutto bene
non posso andare più chiare e fateci
sapere nei commenti se voi l'avete fa
tornare in prigione lo stesso siete
riusciti a scappare non riusciremo ad
evadere non abbiamo fatto niente di male
ecco giallo oppure presso tutti i verdi
in forno
dobbiamo scegliere potremo scegliere fra
outfit io quello arancione quella
striscia di arancione che bella la bella
attrice più classica rock e ridiamo a
335 queste emozioni a 4 a loro quello
era quello sbagliato
ok sto facendo la doccia con dei chicchi
di riso
dobbiamo fare ha detto del prendi una
saponetta o continuano a parti
continuano a farmi 38 ok in prigione
l'altra stanno facendo sport prete si
ricordato che io avevo chiesto rapporti
nel mondo porterebbe li farò dice
aiutano e o ignora lo aiutiamo il
bluetooth e libera sta aprendo
siamo liberi mi chiamo no non mi sa che
cosa sta succedendo
hanno solo sistemare un cacciavite
semivuoto un cacciavite ho capito forse
lo saremo per provare a scappare
[Musica]
ecco cacciavite speriamo di non far male
a nessuno e forse vuole evadere i
detenuti hanno da 39 anni cosa sta
succedendo ora stiamo aprendo la porta
fare e di discendere ok fi all'altro ok
ok ok che al 3 agosto e devo spiegare
che la mano ma sei bravissima scrivo
sempre chiusi ma solo uno è rimasto ci
sei quasi si sei riuscito a scappare non
ci credo se non riuscite a st persona
dalla cgil per adesso adesso ci saranno
le guardie questo è un corridoio
lunghissimo e poi si una porta cosa
scelgo destro stili 3 quello che ti ho
detto che era stato un bel mi piace
perché a 5 milioni piace continueremo
che fa fare il primo problema però 100
anni è una domanda per voi vediamo se
siete stati attenti c'è qualcosa che è
cambiata durante il video qualcosa che è
scomparso è apparso scrivete nei
commenti se sapete che cosa vediamo cosa
siete state sente ora mila sono qua
pasta casellina da pubblicare per vedere
i nostri archivi che calano quelle
preferite